hello everyone I hope you're all having
an excellent Sunday and here we have a
very interesting game from the
penultimate round of the United States
Championship 2018 between Alexandra nice
Chuck and Samuel Shanklin now this isn't
the first video I'm doing on Samuel
Shanklin as some of you may remember
those of you who were subscribed to my
channel maybe even before I had 1000
subscribers I did the game I was from
the Capablanca Memorial in Cuba I
believe it's in 2016 where similar
Franklin's played against vasily von
Schuch
in that video I also said something more
about Wesley about Samuel Shanklin so if
you want to check it out there will be a
link in the description below to that
video it's a really old video before I
improved my my audio and there was even
some music in the background but you
know you're welcome to check it out it's
a very nice game by Evangel and also by
by Shanklin but this game it's a very
interesting game because you will very
rarely see something like this at such a
high level so at one point in the game
one of the players overlooks or maybe
even both of the players I haven't seen
the interview after the game a tactic
that's not very complicated is
overlooked by one or by both of them and
it doesn't affect the outcome of the
game the the player that should have
gotten the advantage if the tactic was
played wins the game anyway so it's very
interesting and it will be a very nice
tactic for you to solve if you haven't
seen the game already so let's see it on
each Cook has the white pieces and he
opens with d4 we have 92 s6 c4 and E 6
so as you know going into this round
Samuel Franklin is leading by half a
point ahead of Fabiana Caruana he has
the black pieces in this game and if he
wants to still you know keep his chances
he has to at least draw this game but of
course it would be even better if he
want Knight to f3 we have the anti names
of variation and now d5 transposing into
the Queens gambit declined Knight to c3
and Bishop to b4 the Ragusan variation
this is probably the most often played
variation today seek after Sundy 5e
capture son d5 and Bishop captures on g5
I meant of course the most often played
a variation of the
we declined h6 we have Bishop to h4 we
have castles III and Bishop to f5 now a3
but should captures pawn captures and
the Knight B to d7 and here on issue
goes for Bishop to e2 Bishop to d3 seems
like seems like a more reasonable move
and it it's a move that doesn't allow
black so much activity as you'll see in
the game in the game of Bishop 3 2 was
played and immediately we have c5
attacking white strong Center we have
castles by oh nice chicken dinner comes
g5 Bishop to g3 and now 94 attacking the
bishop and g3 so whenever black wishes
he can add the private white of the
bishop pair and also attacking the pawn
and c3 so c4 no one likes a backwards
pawn we had D captures on c4 Bishop
captures on c4 and now rook the c8
threatening seek after Sundy for so the
bishop would come under attack rook the
c1 developing the rook also defending
the bishop and Queen to e7 Bishop to d3
we have rook F to e 8 and now Queen to
e2 getting the Queen out of the D file
that is also occupied by the rook and
9th to b6 here night to b6 threatening
Bishop captures on g3 for example if
white played something like D captures
on c5 that would actually open up the D
file then I move like this would be
deadly but she captures and then pawn
captures and image capture Sundy three
wins the piece and end the exchange
after this would be this would be
winning for black so we have Bishop
captures on e4 eliminating the knife
Bishop captures and a nice to e5 now C
capture son d4 rook captures on c8 rook
captures on c8 and it captures on d4 so
if you look at this position White has a
White has a monster knight on e5 which
is obviously excellent to the bishop on
e4 is under attack from the Queen you
have to do something about this and all
in all the position is somewhat equal
blacks King is a bit more exposed but
you know all in all all in all seemingly
an equal position Bishop to a5 getting
the best part
and now Queen to h5 attacking the h6
born f6 now offering the h6 pawn but you
know you're gonna lose the knight on e5
and here Knight to g4 getting the knight
out of the way
a possible continuation was definitely
Queen captures on h6 with the idea of
giving up the knight on e5 for example
pawn captures Bishop captures with some
Queen h8 ideas but after Queen h7 Queen
kept percentage if I would check Queen
blocks and even after the exchange of
Queens black would be up a knight but
white would have a 3 connected pass
bonds as compensation so it's hard to
say if white could actually make use of
this but obviously obviously
Samuel Shanklin didn't think so so
Knight to g4 there's no reason to do it
if you don't know that it's actually
winning Bishop captures Queen captures
and the Queen to d7 now offering a trade
of Queens Queen to f3 on issue that
clients this we have Knight to d5 and
Queen to h5 King to g7 defending the h6
pawn also not allowing the Queen to
alpha infiltrate we are Queen to g6 and
here comes the move that every one in
the world was talking about yesterday
if you're if you follow chess you know
on social media then you probably saw it
but if you don't it's a very nice
position for you to analyze here on each
- played f4 and he might have played f4
because he couldn't find in anything
else to play him he might have known
that it doesn't really work so it could
also be a bluff but if it was a similar
angle didn't call it here Shanklin
played Queen to e8 but in in fact f4 is
a terrible blunder that loses the game
now but you're you're very welcome to to
try and find out why so pause the video
here figure out why f4 doesn't work and
here's your chance
you are Samuel Franklin beat Alexander
Oni shook and continued your lead in the
United States Championship so there you
have it I hope you were successful for
those of you who found this
congratulations you are excellent in
chess tactics and for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show maybe you're
just feeling a little lazy and Sunday
the movies actually in night captures on
a four seems pretty reasonable you grab
a pawn you're attacking the Queen on age
five and after better captures then
comes Queen captures on d4 this is a
would check and now White has two
options the first one let's say rook to
f2 this losses to rook see - now you
attack the paint piece the only way to
defend the rook is actually Queen to f3
and now you simply capture rook captures
Queen captures Queen capture screen
captures and pawn captures on f4 you are
up you are up two points so okay you're
gonna lose this one but still you're
gonna be up upon and you have a
two-to-one advantage on the Queen side a
completely winning position for black
another thing
after this after this Knight captures on
f4 Bishop captures Queen captures you
could also instead of rook to have to go
King to h1 but this is this is even
worse Queen captures on f4 and again
black is now up like it's now up two
points and again it's a winning position
but maybe it will take a bit longer of
course you cannot capture the Queen if
you capture the Queen then Roxy one will
be checkmate after you after white gives
up all of all of his pieces this will be
checkmate so it's very interesting this
is something that was missed and on such
a high level not a tactic that will be
often often missed but okay in the game
Samuel Franklin plays Queen to e8 we
have Queen to f3 attacking the knight on
d5 and now Queen to III check forcing a
trade of Queens Queen captures Knight
captures discounts with an attack on the
rook rook to f3 and now Knight to d5
rope to c1 check doesn't really give you
anything so no point in doing it
not nice Knight to d5 we have pawn
captures H captures on g5 and h4 now
trying to simplify G captors on edge for
Bishop captures on h4 pressuring the f6
pawn and King to f7
Bishop back to e1 we have B 6 and the
bishop to d2 rook to c2
attacking the bishop rook to d3 and
although the material is equal on the
board and you might think that White has
an advantage it's a bishop against
tonight but look at
how passive White's position now is this
is a lonely point on before that that's
currently only defended by the rook and
it's a very passive position for the
rock this rock isn't really doing
anything okay it's protecting the deep
one as well as the a porn but it can't
really move anywhere so King to e6
bringing the King into the game
g4 we have King to d6 and King to f1
white also brings the King into the
action King the c6 we have King to e1
and now King to b5 bringing the King all
the way to C for g5 now giving up a pawn
for a pawn pawn captures Bishop captures
and now keep the c-4 attacking the rook
on d3 there is no real way to actually
hold this position rook to g3 was played
in the game but even if you play
something like rook to d1 with the idea
of still guarding this pawn and then you
get rook to a 2
you attack the a3 pawn now you have to
defend this Bishop to c1 and now you get
rook to h2 and now white is completely
passive and black will simply improve
his position until he until he gets
enough advantage to win the game for
example Rock h1 check pick up the rook
and then pick up the D pawn and the DI
pawn will soon fall so after King to c4
on issue cried rook to g3 we have knife
to c3 you could also capture the pawn
first but there's always time for that
d5 there's no way of saving the points
of Knight captures on d5 and now King to
d1 attacking the rook rook to c3
offering a trade of rooks this of course
makes no sense for white as if he
captures then the F pawn will fall and
it will be a 2 to 1 2 to 0 advantage on
the Queen side Rock to g4 check we have
King to B 3 and now rook to d4 attacking
the knight Knight to e3 check Bishop
captures rook captures and King to d2
attacking the rook rook to h3 and it was
in this position that Alexander only
took resigned the game there is really
nothing you can do here Black is just
gonna capture the pawn and then it's 2
against zero completely winning position
if you play a four then of course you
get rock h2 check King moves and rook to
a
- and now there is really no way of
saving the a pawn so yeah after this I
believe
rook to h3 yeah this was the final move
Alexander on issue resigned and yet
another victory for Samuel Shanklin and
that's what I meant it's a very very
strange that you will see this in in a
game of such a high level that a tactic
like this was missed Knight captures an
f4 which I'm sure you'll agree as I'm
sure most of you have found it but you
know either Shanklin believed an issue
that this actually isn't a blunder or or
I don't know what happened here if any
of you saw an interview if there even
was an interview or any of you are
familiar with the situation please do
share in the comments as I also enjoy
learning new things so yeah that's
that's basically the game I do hope you
enjoyed it and I did prepare the
standings and this these are the
standings before the final round today
we have the final round so I'll probably
announce one more announce the results
of the United States Championship today
also show you another game so still in
first place Samuel Franklin
although Caruana also won his game from
round 10 he beat Yaroslav 0 boo but s
shank had also won his game sank
Shanklin is still half a point in the
lead so we have Shanklin Khurana then
Wesley so with 6 out of 10 with 0
defeats still then Hikaru Nakamura one
win one loss and a draw
Alexander Lenderman Jeffries young via
di saw really rubs and I wonder link
Vajrasana Cobian ourselves Arabic and
Alexander oh nice cook in last place
after losing this game against against
I'm sanguine so yeah once again I do
hope you enjoyed it and you know if you
don't mind the lousy audio you're
welcome to check out the game in the
description saem saemmul Shanklin
against the vastly vine chick from the
capo Blanca memorial I would also like
to thank dummy port violets and Peter
combo for a contribution to my channel
thank you a lot I really appreciate it
as usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you for watching and I
will see you soon probably with another
game from the United States Championship
2018
thank you all